[Music]
will you marry me this is not happening
the horse I love you and I always will
I'll keep this to you ready
it was so lovely to see Carol and
Ezekiel's romance what was your reaction
when the when the show run has told you
that they were gonna pair you two
together romantically interesting you
know it's been a little time jump so
that's totally feasible and you know
they're very different they have to they
have the playing the roles in common and
those little survival tactics in common
but they're very different and an icy
and young and kind of excited to see her
open herself up to a mating experience a
little romance what do you think about
the carol ezekiel romance i mean i think
he's kind of corny but you know she's
happy I'm happy which i think is a real
mature way to be you know that's that's
you've watched will you've watched arrow
become a mature person you know he used
to do everything kind of like this and
like when you looking at now we kind of
you know he's an honest straightforward
looks you right in the eyes type of guy
what can you tease it's coming ahead for
Carol and Daryl cuz fans love their
friendships so much and you and Norman
are just electric together I know I
loved I love I love how they have each
other's back I love their relationship
whatever it is I love their relationship
you can look forward the fans can look
forward to more Lord Daryl and Carol see
you rootin for Carol and Daryl I gotta
say I think a lot of people okay yeah I
kind of get it everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]